all right yeah thanks for having me
um I'm gonna talk about the idea of
developing an eye-based business data
analyst using open AI function calling
so before I go into function calling I
actually first want to address the
question what about chpt code
interpreter as this is currently getting
a lot of hype
and so for example if you look on
YouTube there's quite some heavy claims
there that code interpreter is going to
be the end of data analysts right
so I thought all right then looks like I
have to give this a try myself so I
created a simplified version of a data
set I found on kaggle and this data set
actually tracks the page loads and the
unique visitors for each day
and then I uploaded this to the CSV to
code interpreter and asked it to plot
the number of unique visitors per year
and so code interpreter then loaded and
inspected CSV and afterwards it
generated python code it aggregated the
unique Visitors by year and then it
produced a matbot lip chart all right so
this might look nice overall but there's
a big problem here
the correct answer would have been this
question cannot be answered using the
data set as unique visitors is a
non-editive metric this sounds very
technical what I mean by that is you
know if a user actually visited the
website each day in the year this would
result in this user would have
encountered 365 times in this chart here
so the results are complete
overestimation actually
and so overall I'm not very concerned
that code interpreter is going to
replace data analysts anytime soon
I think it's a tool acting greatly
improve the productivity of anybody that
can cope with python but I don't think
it's something that you want to directly
expose to like non-technical business
users
and this brings me to what I actually
want to talk about which is function
calling so imagine that we had have a
comprehensive retail data set we've
talked about retail before how could we
develop a data analyst chatbot that can
answer a query like the one shown here
using function calling that's like the
setup right and for this we would first
create a system prompt and here I'm
showing a very simplified example that
states you're an expert in data
analytics use the provided functions to
answer the user question you're working
with the following data set and then
here I just concatenate the first five
rows of the data set in markdown format
to give it some context
and next we have to describe basically
the functions that the GPT model should
use for example we can specify a
function filter in aggregate
which takes a list of Dimensions that
should be aggregated and a dictionary of
filters that should be previously like
before it applied on the data set
and then we can also specify other
functions such as
at blood times use function which takes
in a metric and produces a figure for
example a plotly plot
and we can then iteratively make this
more complex you know we could add a lot
more functions here for example
something like
plot forecast or maybe even a function
that would identify anomalies or maybe
even run SQL queries and so the
important part to understand here is
that TBT will act like as an agent and
will only return the function name in
the arguments that it wants us to call
but we actually have to implement these
functions ourselves and then actually
call them when it wants us to call the
functions
and so um
to make this more clear I'm going to
show one example in the action diagram
so first as mentioned we have the system
prompt so we sent the system prompt the
user prompt and the function
specifications to the GPT model
and in this case it would return the
filter and aggregate function name with
the arguments year month and store and
as dimensions and a filter for City
equals Heidelberg so given the query it
thinks okay this would be the best
function to you know fulfill this query
and so we would then execute this
function locally so basically in the in
our analyst and then we send a next
request with the full conversation
history where we also include a markdown
sample of the aggregated data frame and
the model then reasons that the next
function that should be called is this
plot time series function with the
metric sales
and so again we would run this function
locally and then finally we would show
the generated figure in the chat window
so this is like the high level idea of
how function calling can be used to
basically develop custom agents that can
in this actually use KCA act as kind of
a data analyst
and so I think overall
um this is kind of the most promising
Approach at the moment especially
regarding production Readiness for
developing such a tool because it has
several advantages you have full control
over the generated plots you can
incorporate all kinds of guardrails uh
you can you know Implement integration
tests all types of stuff but of course
it's not end to end AI you have to
develop these functions yourself that's
kind of the downside here and then yeah
we're hiring
[Applause]
so next up is Tim